you were mentioning earlier difference  between conservatives and Republicans  especially in Idaho do you find that as  conservatives that people tend words  toward libertarianism but that they  don't don't adopt the libertarian party  because it's too small or something uh I  don't think that it's too small I think  the issue ultimately is is kind of on  abortion like like they won't go to the  libertarian side because of abortion and  also because of kind of law enforcement  really like they just love law  enforcement no matter what they do and  this would be the this would be the  establishment and the conservatives like  uh but people are waking up that there's  good law enforcement there's bad and  that uh and it can be very dangerous and  so I would say if there was two issues  it would be that it would be you know  libertarian view on on abortion and then  also just law enforcement and their role  and and who they are and what they do